pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
verhaegue essayer ce pont d'atr du site
d'information sociale tri palio bonsoir
eric verhaegue merci les frais avec nous
une semaine deux quoique bien remplir
pour emmanuel macron qui se serait bien
passé des dernières fr première réaction
un petit peu globale ça arrive à tous
les gouvernements ou là il ya vraiment
un problème sérieux en macro ni il ya en
tout cas un cap c'est à dire que
visiblement il ya eu une réunion de
groupe à l'assemblée nationale où
certains députés ont commencé à dire le
problème car ils ont pas nommé emmanuel
macron desk on n'en est pas encore au
stade où l'on on prononce le prénom du
roi mais manifestement les députés
commencent à contester le leadership des
manuels macro donc ce qui est
incontestablement un passage dans
l'histoire de ce quinquennat c'est à
dire que l'image du président est
aujourd'hui suffisamment dégradées ou
abîmés pour que lui arrive ce qui est
arrivé à françois hollande avant lui
c'est à dire mise en cause par les
troupes alors c'est marrant parce que
j'avais effectivement vous parlez de
françois hollande la hollande on a tous
en tête de cette fronde à la gauche de
la gauche là en l'occurrence cette
réunion à laquelle vous faites allusion
c'est après voilà le trouble jeté sur le
débat sur le deuil après un enfance ce
congé rallonger ou non qu'est ce que ça
dit effectivement du climat actuel ça a
été un peu la goutte d'eau pour les
députés qui jusqu'ici était
effectivement de bons soldats qui voter
les textes comme on l'elysée là ça mais
ça n'est pas passé
taquiné je vais être un peu taquin on
peut penser qu'un certain nombre de
députés ne comprenait pas forcément la
portée de tous les textes qu'ils
votaient ce qui les aider
ça va pas la faire aller volonté mais là
c'est vrai que cette affaire de congé
après le deuil d'un enfant pour le deuil
d'un enfant
est une affaire qui est extrêmement
sensible intuitive et puis dans la
glaise en quelque sorte et qui était
d'ailleurs une forme de piège tendu au
gouvernement c'est à dire que c'était
extrêmement compliqué d'aller contre ce
texte qui était présentée par
l'opposition
et ils sont tombés dans le panneau et le
gouvernement aussi probablement parce
que le problème de fond c'est que le
gouvernement est dirigé par des
technocrates qui n'ont aucun sens
politique et très peu de sens humain et
on voit bien que en effet les députés
aujourd'hui de la majorité considère
qu'ils ont été extrêmement usés par une
pratique du pouvoir qui consiste à dire
comme je les lui tout à l'heure sur le
net
des ministres qui disent les députés de
la majorité sont là pour voter comme on
leur dit pour fermer leur gueule et je
crois que dès lors qu'on traite les
députés comme ça il faut pas les lâcher
rase campagne le fait que derrière le
président leur fasse des reproches pour
finalement avoir trop obéit au
gouvernement c'est évidemment une
position très compliqué à défendre qui
je pense va semer fortement le trouble
et durablement le trouble sachant que à
mon avis la discussion sur la réforme
des retraites
la discussion du texte avec ses fameux
dix neuf mille amendements de la france
est soumise
cette discussion va profondément laissé
des traces parce que on a du mal à
comprendre qu'une réforme qui a mis deux
ans à être préparés soit aussi bâclée et
soit aussi mal ficelé et exige des
parlementaires autant de renoncements à
la démocratie on va parler plus en
détail dd2 soucier des retraites et de
l'obstruction en tout cas c'est ce que
dénonce l'opposition
qu'est ce que ça dit effectivement
toutes ces affaires la circulaire
castaner la ferme ia avec la réaction de
la garde des sceaux c'est que tout est
plus ou moins improvisées mal préparés
on arrive devant le fait accompli et
voilà ça ne passe pas je pense qu'il ya
deux sujets différents
via sur un ferme il a une très grande
ambiguïté de la république en marche de
macron de son équipe sur la question de
la laïcité sur la question de la
relation à l'islam et je pense que cette
ambiguïté elle est de plus en plus
difficile à tenir
et elle suscite de plus en plus
d'hostilité au sein même de l'opinion et
je pense qu'elle jouera un très vilain
tour emmanuel macron en 2022
s'il se représente parce que cette
ambiguïté fera la victoire de marine le
pen au second tour de la présidentielle
en 2007 c'est ce que vous prédisez pour
quelle raison ça veut dire qu'on
n'assume pas les choses on n'arrive pas
à trancher dans un sens ou dans l'autre
aujourd'hui il est évident qu'il ya une
majorité grandissante dans le pays
ça a été longtemps une minorité et jour
après jour ça devient une majorité qui
considère qu' il faut un discours clair
vis-à-vis de l'islam et qu'il faut
notamment être extrêmement sévères
vis-à-vis des débordements salafistes ou
intégristes auquel on assiste partout en
france et est quotidiennement et donc je
pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui une majorité
de français y compris à gauche qui
considèrent que le moment est venu
d'expliquer aux musulmans de france
qu'ils doivent être sans ambiguïté du
côté de la république sinon ils n'ont
plus leur place dans ce pays il ya eu ce
discours eric verhaegue au lendemain de
la tête de la préfecture ya plus de
quatre mois
emmanuel macron justement ça a été un
petit peu critiquer maucaillou un
tournant l'hydre islamiste la société de
vigilance
le discours est clair est-ce que ce soit
plutôt les actes il ya eu des
déclarations d'intention mais c'était
humiliant que lorsqu'on entend la
ministre bennoo et qui comme pas
n'importe quel ministre et garde des
sceaux qui connaît le droit garde des
sceaux qui connaît le droit invoqué ce
qui ressemble à un blasphème
l'interdiction du blasphème en france ça
pose un vrai problème sur la façon dont
on tire les conséquences du discours
va-t-en-guerre du président de la
république de l'époque mais qui l'a
fortement écornée en expliquant que
l'algérie avait été victime de
l'équivalent du shower en tout cas une
phrase qui était suffisamment ambigu
pour dramatiser ce qu'a été la présence
française en algérie qui rappelons le
est une forme de colonisation comme les
arabes sont des colons en algérie les
vrais algériens ne sont pas arabes
rappelons le donc je pense qu'il ya ce
sujet il ya un deuxième sujet qui pousse
problème c'est que emmanuel macron a
ouvert une crise très profonde dans les
élites françaises dans la
technostructure française et que
lorsqu'on lit les textes du conseil
d'état vous avez parlé de l'annulation
de la circulaire castaner par le conseil
d'état au contentieux
on peut parler évidemment de l'avis du
conseil d'état sur le projet de loi de
réforme des retraites quand on lit les
textes du conseil d'état on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron n'est pas seulement
contesté par les gilet jaune
il est aussi contestée par la haute
fonction publique qui considère qui
commet des dérives autoritaires qui ne
sont plus acceptables et ça je pense que
c'est un signal qui est sur le fond
beaucoup plus dangereux pour lui que les
polémiques ponctuelle au parlement et
malgré tout le gouvernement semble
vouloir être déterminé à poursuivre
notamment sur cette réforme des
retraites hier encore une journée
manifestation se poursuit oui parce que
en réalité le gouvernement edouard
philippe agit comme la poule qui est sec
de piqûres et le grain de l'autre côté
de la vitre et qui au lieu de contourner
l'obstacle continue à d
minimes ans a tapé dedans et donc
aujourd'hui on a en effet cette étrange
aveuglement du pays et ma conviction est
que emmanuel macron edouard philippe
font le pari que leur obstination sur
récompensé aux élections municipales par
des français qui vont dire au moins ils
ont tenu je pense que c'est un pari
extrêmement incertain et par ailleurs il
est très coûteux en terme de cohésion
sociale parce qu'on voit bien que
derrière petit à petit à mesure que les
gens mettent le nez dans le projet de
réforme des retraites
ils s'aperçoivent qu'en réalité c'est
mal ficelé et que ce sera un texte
dangereux y compris au regard des
objectifs qui avaient été affichés à
l'époque par emmanuel macron comment
peut-on en sortir de cette séquence
parce qu'on sait que souvent les
mémoires sont courtes
on oublie et au moment de la
présidentielle ça sera peut-être oublié
mais comment en sortir
hormis aujourd'hui moi je pense que
emmanuel macron a intérêt à provoquer un
big bang soit en organisant un
référendum sur les retraites et en
contournant l'obstruction parlementaire
en appelant directement un arbitrage
populaire ce qui est à mon avis la façon
la plus propre de sortir leur lot de la
situation soit en dissolvant l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'elle va devenir très
vite un gouvernement
certains chirac on a fait des frais
alors jacques chirac avait perdu sa
majorité mais il avait gagné sa
réélection et les cajas grâce à eau sale
boulot qui avait fait lionel jospin à sa
place il avait pu se présenter triomphal
aux élections de 2002 est en réalité le
sujet de d'emmanuel macro est loin avec
dans un contexte particulier certes mais
qui sera grosso modo le même c'est à
dire que
en réalité manuel mal convaincre on a le
choix soit de faire le sale boulot
lui-même soit de le faire faire par les
autres et de revenir triomphant dans
deux ans et demi ou pas d'ailleurs
devant les électeurs merci eric avec va
rester avec nous en direct sur arte
france